now some breaking news the conservative
mp and former government minister james
brokenshire has died he was 53 and was
known to be suffering from lung cancer
he went public on that even although
he had not been a smoker because he felt
the disease was stigmatized the
chancellor rishi sunak has said james
brokenshire
was a man of public service and the
highest integrity he was a valued friend
and colleague and will be deeply missed
my thoughts are with his family on this
incredibly sad day also a tribute on
twitter from zakir starmer the labour
leader james brokenshire was a
thoroughly decent man dedicated and
effective in all briefs he held he
forced his illness with dignity and
bravery i'm incredibly sad to learn of
his death and send my condolences to his
wife and children uh mr brokenshire had
been an mp since 2005
first for horn church and then for
old bexley and sidcup
where he had a majority of over eighteen
thousand he served in the government
latterly as a security minister uh
before that he held posts as northern
ireland secretary and also housing and
communities secretary
james brokenshire who died yesterday
evening